each Opie's not sorted naturally out of
what you guys are doing right now it
would be criminal for us not to look at
it and it's just a really really
beautiful confluence of all these
concepts that you have spent the last
month and a half
developing that's how long we've been
thinking about this kind of thing and
three videos okay so what you've noticed
what you've noticed is that there are
functions with odd n even symmetry right
so I just called them fine and even
functions when we're thinking at the
moment right all the web been dealing
with his polynomials okay so it's just
polynomials of order and even powers
okay so for instance Prince's this guy
here right is your quintessential even
function okay and we already know that
on the basis of this guy
what's our derivative read not to it's
very good
now X square is an even function and
it's derivative F dash is odd you looked
at all months right for example let's
add a new function by the way after f
function G for Junction is the next most
popular on now if we think about the
next polynomial ax and the next direct
excute having an odd power it's it's
always fun you only just got it it's a
yeah that's true that's pretty bad the
derivative of G G dash is of course you
can read off three x squared
G is odd I might even put these on come
on G is odd and then G Dash is even
which is exactly the reverse of what we
noticed up here and I could multiply
examples I could multiply exhibitors
right like X to the power of a hundred
is going to be on or even it's an even
function in fact X to the hundred it
just looks like a really really steep
version of x squared it's a it's x
squared that's gone on the Paleo diet
basically okay ah and that's right it's
what yes so rather than rather looking
like this right excellent Hydra would
look something more like this basically
okay so it's even its through and it was
going to be on so what's going on here
right like just before when we saw this
like these these power businesses we
thought there's got to be a pattern here
I could take advantage on right and
there was and we worked out we derived
it okay
they must be pattern here how do we
identify okay well I'm going to consider
he's where you can follow along with me
I'm gonna consider ear farm must do odd
first if f is odd okay once we go
through this proof you'll see it's
almost identical if we were to reverse
the situation and think about if F were
even we only really need to do wants to
demonstrate what's going on now if F is
odd then by definition what do we know
about F what can we say about F
think think in terms of think in terms
of our notation here write f of minus X
is equal to minus f of X that's the
definition of an odd function right and
then we think about the symmetry that
comes out of that okay now what I want
is to therefore prove what I'm required
to prove is I'm looking for its
derivative being on the derivative sorry
this is all I want to do it to be even
right so why want f dash X I want that
to be even
so therefore what can I say about F dash
F dash of negative x right come on six
there we go that should be true that
should be true okay now we have done a
lot of pest principles right so we know
what F dash X is never know so we know
what this looks like so let's have a go
at this guy let's tackle this guy right
it's over your right hand side equals
negative x what is this thing okay well
it's the limit as H approaches zero of
what well every time I normally just
speak picture first principles you head
everywhere I see an X I'm going to put a
minus X in its place does that make
sense yeah so I've got my limit right on
the top here I would usually have f of X
plus h but I'm thinking about minus X so
this will be minus X plus h I'm just
evaluating it at a different spot - now
normally I would put it after the X on
here but instead I'm gonna put F of
minus next question
okay no no no no she's right she's right
it usually is X plus h right but think
about what this means right
if for instance I wanted to get the
derivative and I don't notice a certain
point five okay all that means is H
approaches zero off okay now what's
gonna be on the top it's gonna be five
plus a little bit right - five like that
okay so five five is the place I'm
looking at right that's the particular
spot where I want the derivative okay
the particular spot here that I want the
derivative is that minus X I guess this
would be thinking you're like the
opposite side right you've got it over
here and now we can the opposite side of
it of the axis so I still want to go
there plus a little bit all right
plus some of that's all I'm doing okay
and you can see it here as well like if
this was minus X then this will be minus
X plus a little bit plus h does that
make sense
just be on this side yeah exactly right
okay so it would be like over here and
over here
maybe minus X and then X plus h and then
I'd get my etc oh that is a great
question and we're gonna answer it in
about two half minutes so let's get now
remember how we started this we said by
definition that F is 1 so this is true
right
so therefore in here and let's just be
super careful with our brackets right I
want to take advantage of this fact so
I'm going to rewrite this guy and F of
minus X minus H why am i doing that
it's because it allows me to use this
property that whole thing in there has
to be negative right so I pop a minus
sign right there okay and that whole
thing in there is negative okay all
right now I've already got this in the
form that I want I recognize that this
is going to be equal to this right
you're following with me that's all
divided by H
okay now I'm going to execute the odd
part of the function so this is the
limit as H approaches you're off by
definition I should be able to put a
minus sign at the front there minus f of
X minus H you see what I did there
okay a lot of functions can do this that
- I can hop out the front precisely
because it's odd not for any other
reason in exactly the same way this guy
can come out the front and it clashes
with this double-bagging airfreight so V
Plus everybody you hear that okay now I
like things to be neat I don't like the
negative at the front and a plus in the
middle so I'm just gonna rewrite that
like so and then I get yes now you stare
at this long and hard
this looks strange this is simplified
for sure I've gotten rid of a lot of
like random minus signs out there okay
but it's not like anything that I'm
super familiar with okay except it is
it's just in different clothes do you
remember we gave you I gave you this
definition of first principles right I
also give you gave you that um that's
like a different one the limit as C
approaches X so f of C minus f of X that
way we'll get it around anyway whatever
that different form of first parentals
is it's still doing the same thing now
what would this be what would it look
like
here is regular first principles up at
all okay that's regular first principles
this is X this is X plus h right so I
have this run here that's why it's on
the denominator okay and then remind me
again what am I got here I've got the
rise here write this f of X plus h on
the top f of X on the bottom and then
this distance here is you take the
difference hence the last so what would
this look like X plus h is X plus a
little bit X minus H is X minus a little
bit I've gone the other way okay
with X and X plus h here I've got X and
X minus H is behind me
does that make sense X plus h goes a
little that way X minus H goes a little
that way
tell me what's this distance here it's
still H isn't it just H the other way
it's still okay now it's just a distance
it's just the distance run is just the
distance now if that's X minus H and
that's X what's this Y Corden over here
this is a vet and what this why corn
over here so what is this distance isn't
it this it's just that right now think
about this remember and this is the
beauty of it right we're thinking about
we said it one two three four times that
tangent not the secant so X going that
way
it's gone this way I don't care H is
gonna be nothing once I've evaluated it
right it's give me a tangent not a
seeker so therefore this these two
pictures did you notice they're the same
picture right this is still F - all
right it's still the gradient at that
point because H is gonna vanish off to
zero
wasn't my head side again it was this
that's the right-hand side
f - minus X is equal to F - it's even
the derivative from first principles of
an odd function must be an even function
and of course you could rehearse this
all over again
you just have minus signs in slightly
different spots if instead you started
with an even function down here you
would end up with an odd function when
you do the derivative okay I think
that's extraordinary